[Musique]
je ce îile
d'amour
pays où j'ai vu le jour j'aime tes prè
rivages et ton maquis
sauvage j'ai vu des lieux
enchanteurs
pourtant au fond de mon
corp je
t'appartiens toujours
toujours au
[Applaudissements]
vieni vieni vieni vieni vieni tu sei
bella bella bella bella bella bella
canta a me vieni vieni vieni vieni vieni
tu sei bella bella bella bella bella
bellaant a me Paola Mia
Rondinella sei la più bella n
mi
PA
[Musique]
il y aura des
étoileses sous la boute des
cieux aura dans la nuit sans
voile du bonheur pour les
gu nous les gar en
fortune nous avons ns
trésors et seul un rayon de
lune V le plus beau
décord quand qu'il y aura des
étoileses sous la voûte des cieux il
aura dans la nuit sans
voile du bonheur pour les
gu ce soir
onina
[Musique]
commentim je pourrais te gliser de foles
caresses et m'en livré du parfum de ta
jeunessee ce soir Nina
oui tu
verras tous les deux nous vibron
chanteureus je t'aurai dans mes bras
[Musique]
N
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
reste encore dans mes
bras avec toi je veux jusqu'au
jour danser cette RB
d'amour son rythme
doux nous emporte bien loin de tout ver
un pays
mystérieux de beau pays des rêv
FL contre ton épaule tandis que nôle je
vois tes yeux qui m d'un regard plein de
douceur et quand nos cœurs se confondent
je ne connais rien au monde de
meilleur
Mar reste encore dans mes
bras avec toi je veux jusqu'au jour
danser
cette
d'amour
oh catarinette belle et
l'amour pourquoi dire non
maintenant faut profiter quand il est
temps plus tard quand tu seras vieille
tu diras baissant l'oreille si j'avais
su dans ce
[Musique]
tempsl oh ma belle
catarinette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant nous allons chanter tii tous
ensemble vous voulez bien écoutez vous
allez simplement chanter les chichi et
les AA et moi je me tape tout le
reste écoute
l'amourpp
pourquoien
maintenant fa profite quand il est temps
ah ah plus tard quand tu seras vieille
tu diras baiss à l'oreille si j'avais su
dans ce temps-là ah ah oh ma belle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
catarineette